only on CBS this morning the American
tourists kidnapped and held captive for
nearly five days in Uganda is opening up
about the terrifying abduction and
terrifying is a word kimberly Endicott
was her name she was on safari in Queen
Elizabeth National Park when four men
kidnapped her and her tour guide now
we're happy to say she's back home in
California just weeks after ransom was
paid to her captors what made you want
to go to Uganda what were you seeking
gorillas you wanted to go see the
gorillas yeah it's something I've wanted
to do probably since I saw gorillas in
the mist and then as I got older I
thought you know you better make this
happen make it happen she did earlier
this month 57 year old Kimberly Endicott
fulfilled a dream on a trip to the
Shasha wilderness camp in Uganda that
first day I'm standing there and all of
a sudden one of them a female comes out
and as she's walking by me she grabs my
inner thigh everybody's like oh my god
and then minutes later another one
nudged me and all the guide said you are
very lucky but her luck would run out
and that dream would become a nightmare
on her third day in the country she
visited Queen Elizabeth National Park
it's a large protected area in the
western part of Uganda a park filled
with the wild animals of Africa a
destination for tourists Kimberley was
driving through the park with an elderly
Canadian couple and their guide JP
Marengo Ramez oh all of a sudden four
men come out of a perfectly square bush
that's in front of us and my first
thought was there must be something
happening behind us and that these are
Rangers why did you think they were
Rangers did they have on Univ their arms
they have guns looking at them it became
apparent pretty quickly that no that's
not what this is they were not in
uniform
they were ragtag and
they made us get out of the vehicle
mm-hmm so are they pointing the guns oh
yes they make us sit on the ground and
that's where things go very I don't know
how to describe it there's really not a
word to describe what that felt like it
pure fear but that almost doesn't do it
justice and then boom and it felt like a
vortex sucking us and the gunman left
the elderly couple behind but told
Kimberly and JP to come with them he had
me by the arm and he was run run run or
I'll slap you run run run or I'll slap
you but that's when I felt him shaking
and the kidnapper was shaking when he
had a hold of my arm and I thought to
myself is this methamphetamines is this
fear so that give you some comfort to
know that maybe he was nervous not yet
yeah because if it's drugs then I'm in a
world of problems so I'm running through
bush hard ground and needles and and I
remember I keep yelling my feet my feet
my feet if you do what we say you'll be
okay and I remember I just kept saying
you took me away you took me away and
this weird gulping that I kept doing I
found out later that's actually a fear
response what are you thinking is going
to happen where is he taking you
that's what I don't know there's still
daylight at this point still daylight
okay still daylight and then the Sun is
setting and we keep walking and it gets
to complete like pitch darkness so at
one point we stopped and I look up in
the sky and I see the most beautiful sky
I've ever seen in my life
mm-hmm and I'm surprised you could
appreciate a beautiful sky at that
moment it was incredible it's nothing
like I've ever seen before and that was
when I became very aware of humanizing
myself to them I said look at the sky
I said we don't have this at home and I
said do you see that that's the Milky
Way that became my mission for myself
was to be human with them not only for
them to see me that way but for me to
see them that way mm-hmm so it's like in
the middle of all of this you're trying
to come up with a strategy it sounds
like very much so are you crying are you
screaming are y'all talking what are you
doing at this mine just being in it were
you thinking that they were going to
hurt you yes attack you constantly I
don't know these men so really well I
was a dialogue hammerhead about that
well how do I get them to shoot me and
just shoot me instead of dismembering me
or raping me how do i how do I do that
if I ran oh I think that would just make
them angry and I think I would probably
get treated pretty badly if I tried to
run and where are you running to by the
way there's no place to run yeah but you
were never physically or sexually
assaulted or no or heard no no but that
was my greatest fear mm-hmm so you
thought if something bad is going to
happen you're thinking please let it
happen quickly yes I have no idea what
they're capable of I have no idea what
their motivation is at this point all I
know is they took me away I liked her so
much guys cuz of course it's only been
two weeks she's still very nervous and
it's still difficult for to talk about
but I said how were you able to even
think how do I be human she remembers
that kidnapping in Atlanta where the
woman started thinking about a
purpose-driven life book and how the
woman in that situation said let me
become human to them and they to me she
said I just went back to that and
thought what can I talk about what can
we do and in the end she really did end
up having a conversation so much so that
when it was over they said Kimberly
we'll miss you Kimberly can we stay in
touch we'll talk about that in the next
half I explained how she eventually got
and how she eventually got out and how
she's back home listen she's a mother
she's a grandmother her daughter's 38
years a seven year old granddaughter
she's a really really real
amazing woman I'm excited to hear more
yeah in our next out and I'm gonna bring
it to you next Erin or will bring you
more of our Kim conversation with
Kimberly Endicott she shares the details
of the release and how the ordeal still
torments her today